HEADLINE, HAVE FUN WITH IT.
WELCOME TO "HANNITY."
BUSY NIGHT.
WE'RE TRACKING SEVERAL BIG
STORIES INCLUDING INFORMATION ON
THE FISA ABUSE REPORT.
FALLOUT SURROUNDING ANOTHER
MASSIVE LIE FROM THE PRESIDENT
CALLS IT POCAHONTAS ELIZABETH
WARREN AND ALMOST AS BAD AS
LYING AS THE CORRUPT MEDIA MOB
AND THE CORRUPT COMPROMISED ADAM
SCHIFF.
I'LL TELL YOU ABOUT A NEW
INVESTIGATION INTO CREEPY,
SLEEPY, QUID PRO QUO JOE.
FIRST, WE START WITH A CLOSER
LOOK AT THE MAINSTREAM MEDIA MOB
AND THEY ARE A MOB AND THEY'RE
ALLIES IN THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
BECAUSE OVER THE PAST WEEK, WE
HAVE WITNESSED MORE OF THE SAME.
MADNESS NOW CONSUMES PRETTY MUCH
99% OF MEDIA IN THIS COUNTRY.
NOW, TO BE A DEMOCRAT OR PART OF
THE MOB, THERE'S NO OBJECTIVE
TRUTH IN YOUR RAGE TRUMP EVERY
DAY WAR.
TO BE A MEMBER YOU HAVE TO HAVE
SELECTIVE MORAL OUTRAGE AND
BREATHTAKING HYPOCRISY.
THE NON-STOP COVERAGE OF THE
IMPEACHMENT CHARADE WASN'T JUST
MADDENING, IT WAS FULL OF LIES
AND OUTRIGHT PROPAGANDA AND
MISINFORMATION.
THEY SPENT A WEEK DIGGING FOR
EVIDENCE THAT DOESN'T JUST EXIST
AND PREDICTABLY, BREATHLESSLY,
HYPING UP TESTIMONY ALMOST ALL
ON HEARSAY CONJECTURE AND WHAT'S
PEOPLE'S INTERPRETATION OF A
TRANSCRIPT AND WE CAN READ IT
AND DECIDE FOR OURSELVES.
NONE OF IT WOULD BE ADMISSIBLE
OR COURT IN A REAL COURT OF LAW.
HERE'S HOW UGLY, SICK AND
TWISTED AND DESPICABLE THEY
REALLY ARE.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> TRUMP ALLEGEDLY ABUSED HIS
POWER FOR PRIVATE GAIN BY
PRESSURING UKRAINE.
>> ABUSE OF OFFICE FOR TRUMP'S
PERSONAL GAIN AT THE EXPENSE OF
US.
>> HE USED THE SECURITY AND
INTERNATIONAL RELATIONSHIPS
WE'RE REQUIRED TO HAVE FOR THE
SECURITY OF OUR COUNTRY AS A
BARGAINING CHIP FOR HIS OWN
PERSONAL GAIN.
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP EXHORTS A
PARTNER WHO'S UNDER DURESS FOR
HIS PERSONAL BENEFIT.
>> WE'RE TALKING ABOUT A BRIBERY
EXTORTION EXTREME.
WHETHER YOU'RE A REPUBLICAN OR
DEMOCRAT, EXTORTION IS
EXTORTION.
>> Hannity: THEY'RE TALKING
ABOUT JOE.
THE SAME PEOPLE AT THE SAME TIME
BIFURCATED, CUT IN HALF THEIR
BRAIN.
THEY LITERALLY SHUT OFF ONE HAM
OF THEIR BRAIN AND DOWNPLAYED
VIDEO EVIDENCE OF THE REAL
CORRUPTION THEY'RE ACTING SO
OUTRAGED ABOUT THAT IN THIS CASE
HAS INCONTROVERTIBLE
OVERWHELMING EVIDENCE.
IN OTHER WORDS, THERE REALLY WAS
A QUID PRO QUO BUT WITH JOE
SHAKE DOWN THE COUNTRY OF
UKRAINE AND BRAGGING ABOUT IT.
NOW, THEY'RE NOT GETTING $1
BILLION UNLESS YOU FIRE THE
PROSECUTOR WHO IS INVESTIGATING
MY ZERO EXPERIENCED SON.
WOW, YOU'RE NOT GETTING A
BILLION UNLESS YOU FIRE THAT GUY
BECAUSE YOU'RE INVESTIGATING
HIM, THERE'S NO EXPERIENCE AND
HE'S MAKING MILLIONS AND
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS.
NOW, STOP FOR A SECOND.
HOW CAN THE SAME PEOPLE ALL LAST
WEEK AND THE MOB AND MEDIA, HOW
CAN THE SAME PEOPLE IN THE NEWS
INDUSTRY, THEY'RE JOURNALISTS.
BE SO OUTRAGED AT PRESIDENT
TRUMP FOR DOING NOTHING, ZIP.
YET, TOTALLY, COMPLETELY IGNORE
THE BIGGEST SLAM DUNK CASE OF
WHAT THEY SAY THEY ARE SO
OUTRAGED ABOUT?
YOU HAVE TO IGNORE THE
INDISPUTABLE FACT THAT HUNTER
BIDEN WAS MAKING MILLIONS AND
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS SERVING ON
THE BOARD OF A CORRUPT UKRAINIAN
OIL AND GAS COMPANY.
YOU HAVE TO IGNORE THE FACT THAT
HUNTER HAD ZERO EXPERIENCE IN
GAS, ENERGY OR UKRAINE AND
IGNORE THE FACT THAT HUNTER
BIDEN WAS HIRED WEEKS AFTER HIS
FATHER WAS APPOINTED TO LEAD
WHITE HOUSE POLICY IN UKRAINE.
YOU HAVE TO IGNORE THE FACT THAT
VICE PRESIDENT JOE BIDEN
LEVERAGED $1 BILLION TAX DOLLARS
AND BRAGGING ABOUT IT TO FORCE
OUT A UKRAINIAN PROSECUTOR, THE
SAME ONE INVESTIGATING HIS SON.
NONE OF THAT IS IN DISPUTE BUT
THE MOB AND MEDIA SAID IT'S ONLY
A CONSPIRACY THEORY.
NO ONE HAS EVER PROVEN IT OR
INVESTIGATED IT.
WE ARE, AND WE'RE GETTING TO THE
BOTTOM OF IT.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> MR. VICE PRESIDENT, PRESIDENT
TRUMP HAS ACCUSED YOUR SON OF
SERVE ONG A BOARD IN THE
UKRAINE.
>> THERE'S NO PROOF THAT JOE
BIDEN OR HUNTER BIDEN DID
ANYTHING WRONG.
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP'S CLAIMS ARE
UNSPAN -- UNSUBSTANTIATED CLAIM.
>> THERE'S NO EVIDENCE OF ANY
WRONGDOING.
IN REALITY, JOE BIDEN WAS THE
ONE WORKING TO PURGE CORRUPTION
FROM THE UKRAINE.
>> AN UTTERLESS BASELESS THEORY.
>> THERE'S NO EVIDENCE NOR HAS
THERE BEEN EVIDENCE THAT HE WAS
DOING ANYTHING OTHER THAN
GETTING UKRAINE TO CRACKDOWN ON
CORRUPTION.
>> LEAVE HIM ALONE.
>> THE BURISMA BIDEN IS A BUNCH
OF B.S.
>> Hannity: THAT'S HOW
DESPICABLE AND CORRUPT THE MEDIA
AND THE MOB ARE.
THERE'S NO EVIDENCE.
WE ALL LOOKED.
IF YOU LOOK AND HEAR JOE
BRAGGING, YOU'RE NOT GETTING THE
BILLION.
HE'S LEVERAGING THE MONEY.
IF YOU LOOK CLOSER, WATCH HUNTER
BIDEN ON GMA, WHAT DID HE DO?
WELL, I HAVE NO EXPERIENCE.
WELL, ONCE I WAS ON BOARD AT
AMTRAK.
OH, THERE'S A TON OF EXPERIENCE.
THIS LEVEL OF GROUP THINK IS NOT
ONLY DESPICABLE, WHAT YOU JUST
WATCHED IS DANGEROUS.
THEY'RE LOSING IT.
NOW, I SAY MOB AND THE MEDIA FOR
A REASON.
THEY ARE A MOB WITH THE MOB
MENTALITY AND A MOB MIND SPENT
THEY DON'T CARE ABOUT THEIR
BREATHTAKING HYPOCRISY AND THEIR
HATRED OF TRUMP AND THE
PROPAGANDA THEY'RE SPREADING AND
THE CONSPIRACY THEIR SPREADING
AND THE HOAX THEY CONTINUE TO
PERPETRATE ONE AFTER ANOTHER
AFTER ANOTHER IN THEIR BUBBLE,
THEIR ECHO CHAMBER.
THERE'S THE REST OF THE COUNTRY
THAT DIDN'T LIVE IN D.C., NEW
YORK, L.A. AND SAN FRANCISCO AND
THEIR BUBBLE IS FILLED WITH
EVERY SECOND OF EVERY DAY, TRUMP
RAGE.
PSYCHOSIS.
VENOM.
IT'S RESULTED IN THIS ENDLESS
STREAM OF FAKE HYSTERIA, LYING,
PROPAGANDA, MISINFORMATION,
SMEARING, SLANDER, DISTORSION
AND EVERYTHING IN BETWEEN AND
THEY'VE BEEN CRYING WOLF FOR
THREE YEARS AND HAVE NOT DONE
ANYTHING FOR YOU.
WE, THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
NOT ONE THING HAVE THESE PEOPLE
DONE EXCEPT BRING US TO THE
BRINK OF IMPEACHMENT.
WOW, TAKE A LOOK.
>> I HAVEN'T SEEN THIS SINCE
OCTOBER 20, 1973 WHEN PRESIDENT
NIXON FIRED ARCHIBALD COX.
>> ECHOS OF WATERGATE.
>> A GIANT STEP TOWARDS
IMPEACHMENT.
>> IMPEACHMENT IMPLICATIONS ARE
IN THE AIR.
>> THE PRESIDENT WILL BE REMOVED
FROM OFFICE.
>> BOMBSHELL.
>> BOMBSHELL STORY DROPPING
SEEMINGLY EVERY DAY.
>> HE WILL RESIGN THE
PRESIDENCY.
>> WARMING TO THE IDEA OF HIS
RESIGNATION.
>> THE WALL'S CLOSING IN AND
HE'S LASHING OUT.
>> HE FEELS THE WALLS CLOSING
IN.
>> YOU CAN FEEL THE THREAD BEING
PULLED.
YOU CAN FEEL THE CLOSE STARTING
TO COME OFF THE CLOTHES STARTING
TO COME OFF THE EMPEROR.
>> DONALD TRUMP IS DONE.
NO QUESTION.
>> SELECTIVE MORAL OUTRAGE AND
THAT'S WHAT THE MOB LOOKS LIKE.
IT'S SAD.
IT'S SICK.
IT'S DANGEROUS.
WHEN THE FACTS DON'T FIT THEIR
NARRATIVE.
THEY LIE.
THEY LIED ABOUT THE RUSSIA HOAX
AND THE INJUSTICE AGAINST
JUSTICE CAVANAUGH.
EVERY DAY THEY LIE WHEN THEY SAY
THEY'RE JOURNALISTS.
THEY'RE NOT JOURNALISTS.
YET, THEY ALWAYS WANT TO
CRITICIZE US.
LOOK AT FAKE NEWS CNN AND ALL
THEIR PHONY REPORTING.
WELL, THIS GUY WOULDN'T HAVE A
JOB HE'S SO BAD AT TV.
THE LOW-RATED STEN O
THE LOW-RATED STENOGRAPHER HE
DOESN'T HAVE A MILLION VIEWERS
ON HIS SHOW AND HE'S CRITIQUING
OF OUR COVERAGE OF THE
IMPEACHMENT CHARADE CALLING IT A
CONSPIRACY THEORY AND MAYBE YOU
WANT TO LOOK AT WHAT POLITICO
SAID ON JANUARY 11, 2017 AND
READ ABOUT ALEXANDER TALUPA AND
HOW SUCCESSFUL THEY WERE IN
TRYING TO HURT AND THEN THEY HAD
A GUEST SUGGESTING PRESIDENT
TRUMP IS USING MIND CONTROL ON
HIS SUPPORTERS AND HUMPTY IS
TAKING ORDERS FROM THEIR FAKE
NEWS CHIEF, FALL ZUCKER.
THE -- PAUL ZUCKER.
THE NEWS NETWORK CHANNEL IS LIKE
ATTACK THE CHANNEL ARE
SUCCESSFUL.
IF IT WASN'T SO SICK IT'S
ACTUALLY FUNNY AND ENTERTAINING
TO ME.
TO DEFLECT FROM THEIR OWN
CONSTANT LYING AND CONSPIRACIES
AND OWN HOAXES, AND OF COURSE
THEIR ANTI-TRUMP BIAS EVERY
SECOND OF THE DAY, THEY JUST LIE
AND MORE AND MORE THEY CLAIM
OTHERS ARE GUILTY OF WHAT THEY
DO EVERY DAY, ALL DAY.
WE HAVE A REAL CRISIS OF
INFORMATION IN THE COUNTRY, MAKE
NO MISTAKE.
FAKE NEWS CNN, AREA 51, YES,
ROSWELL, RACHEL MADDOW'S
CONSPIRACY AND THE WHOLE CHANNEL
WHO TRIES TO DUPLICATE WHAT SHE
DOES THEY HAVE ZERO FIDELITY TO
TRUTH AND ZERO FIDELITY TO THE
TRUTH AND APPLICATION OF THE LAW
AND EQUAL APPLICATION OF
STANDARDS, JOE AND HUNTER.
THAT'S WHY IT'S UP TO US, I
GUESS.
FINE, LEAVE IT TO US.
THE NUMBER ONE SHOW ON CABLE
NEWS, THANKS TO YOU.
WE'LL REMIND THEM UKRAINIAN
INTERFERENCE IN THE 2016
ELECTIONS ACTUALLY HAPPENED AND
WILL VET QUID PRO QUO JOE AND
HUNTER AND THE REST OF THE
DEMOCRATIC FIELD.
THEY'LL NEVER DO IT.
IT WILL BE UP TO US TO CALLED
THE CORRUPT, CONGENITAL GUYER,
SCHIFF AND THE -- LIAR SCHIFF
AND THE SCHIFF SHOW AND TRYING
TO SMEAR AN ELECTED PRESIDENT
AND KICK IT OFF WITH HEARSAY AND
OPINION AND A NON-WHISTLEBLOWER,
WHISTLEBLOWER COMMUNICATING WITH
SCHIFF'S OFFICE EARLY ON.
THE WASHINGTON TIMES THIS
INDIVIDUAL MAY HAVE BENEFIT FROM
ONE OF PRESIDENT OBAMA'S FINAL
DIRECTIVES.
DOING TO THE NEXT PRESIDENT THAT
WHICH YOU DIDN'T WANT IN YOUR
ADMINISTRATION.
GIVING WHISTLEBLOWERS NEW
PROTECTIONS AGAINST THE
EXECUTIVE BRANCH AND THIS CAME
IN THE FINAL MINUTES OF THE
PRESIDENCY AND IN STARK CONTRAST
TO WHEN HE ENTERED OFFICE IN
2009 AND OBAMA WAGED A WAR
AGAINST THIS COMMUNITY AND HIS
ADMINISTRATION PROSECUTED NINE
WHISTLEBLOWERS UNDER THE 1971
ESPIONAGE ACT MORE THAN ALL
OTHER PREVIOUS ADMINISTRATIONS
COMBINED.
BUT THE MOB, PRESIDENT TRUMP IS
BAD AND WELL, OBAMA'S A SAINT.
AGAIN, IT'S CRYSTAL CLEAR.